damn do we have another in cut a moist
one please be juicy it is okay
slim do you do this know why all of
sudden easy involved because I'm their
strawberry daiquiri
I can't believe Philip is put on a show
for me well if you want to know the
truth about a drinker
ask the bartender grant why go home
tonight it's like a comedy America
you're welcome
just for tonight no no what does the lip
normally do at the hotel he does drink
quite a bit well I don't have rich how
many drinks would you make a day during
the day sometimes four or five and it
jumps into the evening it could come up
to seven eight
I am cut out for a new one
Wow no wonder things on the slide with
Philip drinking that much I've got to
get him to tell me the truth this
monstrous hotel has been running
rudderless there's no one at the helm
and you're pretending all of a sudden
I'm busy it makes me tired lifting
because I'm here I just know because
you're here we don't normally do this
stuff this is what I normally do you're
calling a staff lawyers I would say so
they say that I'm not out here helping
them every time I walk in this building
I had to call them [ __ ] liars
[Music]
she's wave a [ __ ] magic wand when the
place is run into the grounds with
dinner service over I'm gonna get Philip
and he starved together so I can finally
get to the truth is that normal what I
witness tonight this Philip always here
does feel always expedite the [ __ ]
hot plate no no we need somebody to
expedite we're understaffed and if we
get busy then we can't give good service
and those people will not come back a
person can't shortcut like dad this
place the business been strangled it's
been strangled by the owner why are we
pretending I'm doing a good job of
pretending then this is what I do every
time that you come in here this is what
you do I do not run the food down to
your bar for the last couple of nights
let's talk about the elephant in the
room shall we when Philips drinking he
behaves one or two different ways either
he's jovial and likes to giggle and have
a good time or if finances are in
arrears that we hear about how much
everything costs you and you are gonna
close the doors it's stressful it's not
easy to come to work with someone
threatening us all the time that the
doors are gonna be closed please don't
look at me like that Philip because you
do do this to us that's [ __ ] you
need your food you have told us over and
over and over again that you're just
gonna show me I may have said that twice
twice come in here regularly and say I'm
gonna close the doors
if we keep lying about [ __ ] and we keep
covering up [ __ ] and whatever then he
ain't gonna [ __ ] help us and here we
go like this like we've been going for
seven [ __ ] years he's he's been known
to walk behind the barn fix himself
drinks after the staff cuts mom
yes is that true that I don't know about
that I don't know about I've gone behind
the bar and made my own drinks yes so
you're blacked out your that and he
berated that you've got no [ __ ] idea
that you're that far gone he goes behind
the bar take the drink away from him you
can not go out to see you in there in
the first place why is he even in that
bar in the first place why is he why
that to me it's hypocritical you put out
memo saying that we can't drink in the
bar it's hypocritical Phillip and we
care about this place and we care about
you but a lot of us feel like you don't
give a damn about us why are you coming
in here to put your employees in a bad
uncomfortable situation if it was up to
me I'd say Phillip you can't drink in
here because if something happens to you
take out a family of four they're coming
after me in my family and I don't have
any money to afford a lawyer keep me out
of jail for the rest of my life